you'll never guess who call me Nick what
do you I just want to go do what he has
to say
Hey look at you wow you're like a soccer
mom medicine everything okay with him
dreaming dreams I'm scheming schemes I
was in detonator
I don't you kidding me I was in a band
with Sully that was a long time you're
all set up here
Chico's into a place it's coming
together things aren't really really
tight
they still riding no you play though
right sometimes you have to make hard
decisions
maybe the hard decision would have been
to stick with it I just have a family
I'm mouths to feed I have goals do you
have any goals yeah
I want to hear our album
she's here to take them you think it's
yours I just need you to be here
get in the car left
why do you think I'm standing here
talking what do you think I want to know
is your killing freeze what are you
doing ladies and gentlemen in case you
forgot um detonator if you got something
to play this one
what is that dad I'm going the garage
and get my dad player you know what that
looks like it's like an old VHS player
top-loading I'm gonna come with you okay